podcast we got a special guest in here
my guy Jay Walt yes sir you're from
Oakland yes sir Oakland in the building
the Bay Area come on you worried about
the uh [__] ass Warriors hey man come
on man we doing good man we just won
last night you're right you're right
you're right right you guys are gonna
win the series that's what I'm saying
we're looking good right now and I'm
just ready to you know go back to the
bathroom you know we win that one I
think we'll see how do you feel about uh
Las Vegas pillaging all your teams man
that [__] hurts man that [__] hurts man
you know I I like Vegas but you know we
Raiders and Raiders is gone you know the
ages left man you know the Warriors went
to Frisco you know so we all we got now
we got this new soccer team Oakland ruse
you know it's coming up and besides that
bro we got none to somebody I know own a
part of the Oakland Roots is G easy
owner or some [__] yeah I think yeah I
think G I think G is the owner of that
yeah do you like do you watch do you go
to Oakland Roots games yeah man I uh I
did man I got invited to one last year I
went to that one I'm about to uh do the
halftime show
um
shout out to uh the bay shout out to
Oakland come on the home of a lot of
legendary MCS legendary uh and we're
gonna let you do what you do man come on
[Music]
Jay what man come on try to eat those
man blue like that what's happening yes
sir yeah yeah
Hey by the [__] man that's my Jordan
year 23 only 21 but I didn't live like I
was 43 party with my brothers we still
brother like we funny deep they're like
where you been [__] I've been working
torn overseas you know where I'd be it's
foreign
I knew what I came for sorry I'm a
player baby I grew up I'm too short I
put on for the West the OG's gave me a
new torch and it beat a rock you know I
smoke it like a new part it's cancerous
these weak [__] thinking that they
don't judge and fight a game until these
weak [__] to go [__] I'm home and I
ain't leaving get to know the name is
Jay Watt and it's my season I'm a top
dog I'm a city for a reason it's funny
once you get some Cloud [__] get to
leeching wasn't with me then I failure
you can keep it they told me I'm a
legend in the making and I see it and
really I ain't rhyming words homie I
believe it only 21 and check the resume
I did it showing eyes and Wu-Tang where
the words
I just found a way so I'm trying to act
like there's no spitters in the bay Drew
while the wrestling symbol We Came To
Stay Rex like Raji and Kelly St spitting
Larry June C5 font say we different what
Daddy seeing no more my brother Frank
Southern Man Mr fat we really rap so
stop sleeping on our region that's a
fact go and get your top spitters you
know where to find a set homie okay you
know what I'm saying hey man shout out
to the Bay man y'all really act like we
ain't got no spitters in the bay man we
here hey man you matching them
incredible shallow Russell shout out to
Simba come on shout out to you man shout
out to everybody in the bay appreciate
you pulling up with your IG and all that
me I can find my Instagram at official.j
Wild that's o f f i c i up here that
j-w-a-l-t and it's only right you got
the LRG on because they're sponsoring
the goddamn freestyles come on Sir shout
out LRG man shout out to everyone man
they be giving me lace me up some good
gear man yes sir LRG man we here
hey I know you just watched a new
freestyle guess what we're dropping them
every week sometimes more than once a
week Jesus we've been dropping a lot
lately uh shout out to LRG don't forget
go to
l-r-g.com use the promo code bootleg
save 30 off at checkout you get this
look at this jacket look at that lining
it's LRG baby 30 off this bad boy go to
l-r-d-g.com promo code bootleg and save
30 off at checkout and check out another
freestyle next week